die Schlagzeile die mich heute am
meisten beschäftigt hat kommt aus dem
Handelsblatt da stand nämlich der
Bundesrechnungshof fordert die Ampel zum
Sparen auf da habe ich erstmal gedacht
was steckt denn dahinter der
Bundesrechnungshof ist ja die externe
Finanzkontrolle des Bundes und der geht
jetzt einem neuen Bericht hart mit der
Bundesregierung ins Gericht der Vorwurf
die wahre Lage unserer Bundesfinanzen
werde aus dem Haushaltsentwurf nicht
deutlich der Bund habe zahlreiche
Ausgaben für wichtige Politikbereiche im
Sondervermögen ausgelagert die
eigentlich aber aus dem normalen Etap
finanziert werden könnte schreibt der
bundesrechnungsschreibt der Rechnungshof
ja ich würde das jetzt mal etwas
einfacher zusammenfassen eigentlich
wirft der Bundesgerichtshof
Augenwischerei vor und die echte
Nettokreditaufnahme sei vierfach höher
als die auf dem Papier vermerkte also
Finanzminister Christian Lindner und
seinem Ministerium wird platt gesagt
Verschleierung im Bundeshaushalt
vorgeworfen und da möchte ich jetzt
natürlich direkt von Herrn Bruder wissen
sind die ich hoffe jetzt zu hart oder
was ist denn da los nein die Vorwürfe
sind überfällig die hatten auch schon
vor einer oder zwei Jahren kommen können
es wird in der Tat ausgelagert mein
schönstes Beispiel dafür mit dem ich nie
gerechnet habe ist das sogenannte
Sondervermögen zu Sanierung der
Bundeswehr abgesehen davon dass da nicht
zu sanieren gibt heißt Sondervermögen in
dem Fall man nimmt Kredite auf soweit
ich weiß ich kann mich täuschen ist es
der erste Fall in der Geschichte der
Wirtschaft der Volkswirtschaft das
Schulden zu vermögen umformuliert werden
allerdings zu einem Sondervermögen und
das wird sonder zeigt schon eine gewisse
Barbara im Umgang mit der Sprache an
Sondervermögen tausend Milliarden kein
Mensch denkt mehr daran wenn er
Sondervermögen hört dass das Geld ist
das vom Bund aufgenommen wird und
eigentlich 100 Milliarden von 100
Millionen würde kein Mensch mehr reden
ja aber das ist es und der
Bundesrechnungshof geht eigentlich noch
sehr milder um er spricht auch vom
Mangel der Transparenz aber das ist das
Geschäftsprinzip man lagert bestimmte
Haushaltsposten aus damit der Haushalt
kleiner erscheint als er ist aber
eigentlich sollte sowas wie das
Sondervermögen zum Haushalt natürlich
umgerechnet werden und deswegen der
Vorwurf der Verschleierung der
Bundesrechnungshof da finde ich auch
sehr zurückhaltend ist man könnte auch
vom betrug sprechen sie würden vom
Betrieb sprechen Frau Seibert wie haben
sie das aufgefasst dass die amply jetzt
sparen soll und der Bundesrechnungshof
da jetzt auch wirklich sagt also so geht
das hier nicht mit dem Haushalt also da
ich keine Finanzexpertin bin kann ich
einfach nur dazu sagen das geht einfach
wie immer ums Vertrauen und da haben wir
einfach jetzt ein großes Problem also
die Politik muss etwas verkünden sie
muss etwas was sie muss Veränderungen
vornehmen und das Vertrauen in
verschiedene Richtungen ist einfach auch
schon in weiten Teilen verspielt wie man
sieht und da ist jetzt einfach gute Rat
teuer
ja vielleicht hat der Bruder ein Rad wie
die Regierung was machen sollte nein
wenn ich Rat hätte die schon längst
darüber im Buch geschrieben aber in dem
Fall wird sich jeder blamieren der so
tut als hätte ein Rad schauen Sie das
Problem ist wir also ich nicht aber wir
haben wirklich Jahre wenn ich Jahrzehnte
mit Geld nur so herumgeschmissen wir
haben den Indern als Volk schätze ich
die sehr wir haben den inneren eine
Milliarde Euro überwiesen für die
Elektrifizierung der Straßenverkehrs
wenn wir jetzt ein Moment leise sind und
genau hinhören können sie hören wie die
Inder immer noch darüber lachen eine
Milliarde für die Elektrifizierung der
ringschatz wir haben den Taliban der
wirklich Namen hungerschutz stehen
dieser wohlgenährten Herren mit ihren
ganz neuen Kalaschnikows den haben wir
600 Millionen Euro überwiesen also Geld
war hier im Überfluss vorhanden und mir
eine Frage und irgendwann Recht sich das
eben sie können auch nicht jahrelang
Geld drucken wobei Geld wieder gar nicht
mehr gedruckt das schreibt sich die
Europäische Zentralbank einfach selber
gut zu denken
Jahre Jahre wahrscheinlich schon
Jahrzehnte permanent Geld in
Milliardenhöhe drucken und verteilen
ohne dass man die Konsequenzen ins Auge
fasst und die erleben wir jetzt ich
meine irgendwann holt einen die
Wirklichkeit immer ein meistens zu spät
Frau Schulter wie schätzen Sie die Lage
ein wie steht Deutschland da
Deutschland steht im Moment so da dass
wir eine Regierung haben die aus drei
außerordentlich unterschiedlichen
Parteien zusammengesetzt ist und jeder
muss ihre Klientel bedienen und
der FDP fällt eigentlich zu das Geld der
Bürger beisammen zu halten und das
nehmen ihr würden ihr nun die anderen
beiden übel nehmen und deshalb wird er
so ein großer Budenzauber gemacht mit
Sondervermögen mit Geldern die
eigentlich
irgendwoher kommen keiner weiß genau
woher das hat alles gar nichts mit der
Schuldenbremse zu tun sondern das ist
irgendwie extra gelagert und wir haben
und hoffe dass es keiner mehr Christian
Lindner erwähnt die Schuldenbremse ja
oft ist da geht ja kaum als nicht vor
erwähnt aber sie sagen die wird nicht
konsequent überhaupt nicht umgesetzt
wenn man Sondervermögen einsetzt das
sind ja letztendlich nichts anderes als
Schulden die nur anders wie Herr Bruder
ja gesagt hat anders deklariert sie
würden also den Vorwurf der
Verschleierung unterstützen in dem Fall
absolut ja Herr Seppel wie sehen sie die
Lage in Deutschland den Haushalt machen
sie sich als Bürger sorgen ich mache mir
Sorgen um die Gesamtsituation der Welt
und nicht nur die Situation in
Deutschland das finde ich problematisch
und kleben zwischen diesem Land fast 60
Jahre und wir haben eine Situation wie
wir sie so noch nicht hatten und das
macht mir großen Kummer und aber ich
sehe auf der anderen Seite ich habe
Menschen und Freundinnen Ukraine ich
weiß wie es den Menschen dort geht und
ich weiß auch Menschen die hierher
gekommen sind denn es überhaupt nicht
gut geht und den wie ich finde wir alle
helfen müssen und deswegen sage ich
unterm Strich immer noch wir Jammern auf
sehr sehr hohem Niveau in diesem Land
und wir werden jetzt eine Situation im
Winter wahrscheinlich haben die
sicherlich manchen Leuten nicht gefällt
wir müssen Einsparungen vornehmen wir
werden Einschnitte erleben
aber ich weiß halt auch dass wir
eigentlich zufrieden sein können es in
diesem Land leben können wenn sie sagen
wir jammern auf hohem Niveau führen Sie
also Ihr Steuergeld noch gut angelegt im
Haushalt und in der Politik ja ich finde
es richtig ich finde es völlig in
Ordnung dass ich so viel Steuern zahle
wie ich zahle ich finde das völlig in
Ordnung sie können freiwillig mehr
zahlen wenn sie wollen gute Idee aber
vielleicht sollte ich das tun aber ich
versuchen auf das ist eine gute Idee
also ich glaube nach der Sendung okay
was sie mir schenken ja nach der Sendung
habe ich was anderes vor nein nein wer
jammern nicht auf hohem Niveau das ist
schon sehr ein bisschen zynisch es gibt
Leute die jeden Euro umdrehen müssen
wirklich ein großen Unterschied ausmacht
ob die Rolle beukeller Kekse 99 Cent
kostet
1,59 € sind und die haben nicht
erforschen aber das meinte ich auch
nicht so ich sage nur dass das ist uns
grundsätzlich in diesem Land meistens
besser geht als vielen Menschen auf der
Welt das ist was ich meine und ich bin
ja vergleichen ja tu nicht wissen Sie
ich bin ja nun durch meine
Berichterstattung in der Welt
rumgekommen und ich habe halt viel
gesehen und weil ich das gesehen habe
relativiert sich für mich manches
trotzdem haben sie völlig recht es gibt
Menschen die denen es nicht gut in
diesem Land geht aber ich weiß halt auch
beispielsweise wenn ich in anderen
Ländern unterwegs bin die haben noch
nicht mal Hartz IV die haben noch nicht
mehr Sozialhilfe da gibt's überhaupt
nichts ja und das ist noch viel
schlimmer das macht es nicht besser hier
das möchte ich das immer schlimmer da
haben sie berecht ja aber das macht das
nicht besser und letztendlich geht es ja
auch nicht nur um das Wohlbefinden von
einigen Leuten sondern es geht auch um
die Wirtschaft und wenn hier tatsächlich
ganze Wirtschaftsbereiche
zusammenbrechen dann hat das ganz andere
Folgen als wenn jemand aus der gehobenen
Mittelklasse vielleicht meinem Pulli
anziehen muss frau Seibert sie sind ja
auch alleinerziehend und haben ja auch
Kinder wie sehen Sie denn die aktuelle
Lage in diesem Land also jammern wir
einfach auf zu hohem Niveau und
eigentlich haben wir alle genug
also ich glaube noch geht es aber es
zeichnet sich ja jetzt ab sie haben
vorhin die Geschichte erzählt mit dem
Benzinkanistern dass die Leute also wenn
mal der Benzinpreis sich entsprechend
verändert dann gleich losrennen und sich
das Benzin abzapfen so welche Szenen hat
man ja in Deutschland
bisher zumindest nach meiner Kenntnis
nicht gesehen und ich glaube schon dass
es jetzt darum geht wirklich genau
hinzuschauen was passiert jetzt wirklich
also ich mache mir auch Sorgen nicht um
mich selbst sondern einfach um um große
Teile der Bevölkerung ich glaube das ist
uns sehr hart treffen wird aber es
gehört jetzt auch ein bisschen dazu
unsere Rolle als Medien hier kritisch zu
hinterfragen ich finde immer
Selbstreflexion wichtig und jetzt schon
wieder von dieser Angst zu sprechen den
Leuten Angst einzujagen das ist eben ein
sehr zweischneidiges Schwert und man
muss ja nach vorne schauen man muss
natürlich die Zukunft planen aber
gleichzeitig geht bei vielen in der
Bevölkerung auch so ein Reflex hoch dass
man sagt nein ich möchte nicht noch mal
mit dieser Angst konfrontiert werden von
Seiten der Medien über die Politik die
Politik verkündet die Medien
transportieren und dann sitzen wir
wieder da und müssen Angst haben also
da habe ich ja auch da bin ich ja auch
gegen aufgestanden gegen diese massive
Angst mache es gibt auch Experten die
sagen sogar wir machen noch zu wenig
Angst weil sie befürchten dass es große
Demonstrationen in Deutschland geben
wird aufgrund der steigenden Preise und
dann auch noch der zurückliegenden
corona-jahre
ja ich glaube man müsste halt einfach
wie praktischer an die Bevölkerung
herantreten warum setzt man jetzt nicht
einfach ein großes Ziel krisenexperten
ein und lässt ja aber wirklich die die
Kurse geben was macht man bei einem
Blackout zum Beispiel ich habe gerade
kürzlich einen kennengelernt durch einen
Zufall in dem Hotel der hat gesagt er
macht professionelles Blackout
Management und der entrichtet die Leute
was wie sie sich vorbereiten können was
passiert wenn wir wirklich weg und haben
sie haben sie haben 20 Minuten Zeit bis
das Handynetz zusammenbricht wusste ich
nicht fand ich hoch spannend 20 Minuten
so weit dass wir Steuerzahler uns auf
Blackouts vorbereiten sollen mir macht
das Angst nicht Kampagne der Medien
haben ich glaube es ist gut wenn man das
mal gehört hat und wenn man sich mal
erkundigt hat okay was was ist wenn wir
wirklich kein Gas mehr haben wie heizt
sich denn also ich stelle mich jetzt
darauf ein vielleicht muss ich irgendwie
mit meinen Kindern in die
schrebergartenhütte und da habe ich
jetzt irgendwie so und so viel Festmeter
Holz da ist aber der Preis ja auch schon
gestiegen oder ich muss in die Berge in
das kleine Bergh also irgendwas muss ich
mir ausdenken viele Leute die haben
weder Schrebergarten berghäuschen und
habe ich auch nicht selbst sondern ich
würde es mir dann bei denen die den es
gehört ausleihen nur so
das sagen alle
löst dass ein Staat der uns immer mehr
vorschreibt was wir zu tun haben wir zu
reden haben welche Pronomen wir benutzen
sollen was wir zu essen haben etc so
eine wichtige Sache der Daseinsvorsorge
vollkommen privatisiert das soll sich
bitte der einzelne darum kümmern was
passiert wenn wir kein Gas mehr da ist
wenn das Handynetz zusammenbricht wenn
vielleicht der nächste Supermarkt
geplündert wird ich muss sagen das ist
ein starkes Stück in Zukunft
zwischendurch einwerfen darf es hat hier
in den letzten Jahren eine Verblödung
stattgefunden wie es in einer
aufgeklärten Gesellschaft noch nicht
gegeben hat ich sag mir nur ein Beispiel
aber es gibt mehr davon bei Baumärkten
sind die Heizlüfter ausverkauft die
Leute kaufen sich elektrische Heizlüfter
aus Angst vor einem Blackout weil bei
denen kommt der Strom da aus der
Steckdose wenn sie Leute so weit haben
dass sie sich dermaßen irrationalen
verblödet verhalten können Sie mit den
Leuten alles machen es kapiert auch
niemand dass der Staat eigentlich kein
Geld hat das Stadt ist nur
verteilungsmaschine aber alle sind
begeistert ich könnte den Leuten weil
sein 9 € Ticket hatten wird nur
vergessen dass das den Start zweieinhalb
bis drei Milliarden Euro gekostet hat
und das Geld kommt irgendwoher nämlich
aus den Taschen derjenigen die mit
Begeisterung für 9 € von Berchtesgaden
nach Kiel fahren also ich glaube es
lohnt sich schon auch ein bisschen
zurück zu gucken auf diesen Sommer also
Leute die sich nie irgendwie über die
Klimaanlage Gedanken machen mussten ist
wir hatten einfach ein unglaublich
heißen Sommer und ich mache mir da schon
Gedanken einfach um die Natur ich nenne
es jetzt mal Natur ne das Klima ist ja
jetzt schon wieder so ein Begriff mit
dem man schon wieder ganz viel
transportiert was man vielleicht gar
nicht will mir macht es Angst wenn ich
sehe dass die Wälder im Taunus
vertrocknen ja das größte
zusammenhängende Waldgebiet nach der
Lausitz wenn ich richtig informiert bin
vielleicht noch den Bayerischen Wald das
ist alles braun sind braun wenn ich aber
jetzt Richtung Bayern fahre wirds schon
wieder grün also ich mache mir Gedanken
um die Natur und um meine Umwelt und
schön ja und das ist für mich ein
genauso großes Thema wie das was jetzt
den Winter betrifft auch wenn wir den
jetzt schon eigentlich hinter uns haben
zwei Kindern auskommen muss dass ihre
primäre Sorge den Wald gilt der
klimawandelt auch wunderbare positive
Effekte die Grönländer ich war neulich
da freuen sich weil die Gletscher
schmelzen sie wieder Tomaten anbauen
können sie Angst vor einem Blackout oder
besuchen sie schon so ein Training weder
das eine noch das andere nicht ehrlich
bin also ich glaube tatsächlich dass die
Situation für manche Menschen diesem
Mann wirklich gefährlich oder im brisant
sein wird ich glaube aber auch wenn ich
höre dass die Gasspeicher jetzt zu 85%
ja demnächst auch schon gefüllt sein
werden wenn das denn stimmt dass das
offensichtlich viel schneller vonstatten
gegangen ist dass wir vielleicht vom
allerschlimmsten verschont sein werden
dass die Preise betrifft ist eine andere
Geschichte aber dass wir einen richtigen
Blackout erleben werden da bin ich
optimistisch dass es nicht passieren
wird